the problem starts to emerge when the
things that you convert into
computational language start to expand
for example into the realm of politics
so this is where it's almost like this
nice dance of wolf from Alpha and uh
Chad gbt Chad gbt like you said is a
shallow and Broad so it's going to give
you an opinion on everything but it
writes fiction as well as fact which is
exactly how it's built I mean that's
exactly it is making language and it is
making both even in code it writes
fiction I mean it's kind of fun to see
sometimes you know it'll write fictional
World from language code yeah that that
term it kind of looks right yeah it
looks right but it's actually not
pragmatically correct yeah um but but
yes it's it's a it has a view of kind of
roughly how the world works at the same
level as books of fiction talk about
roughly how the world Works they just
don't have happened to be the way the
world actually worked or whatever but
yes that's
um no I I agree that's sort of a
um you know we are attempting with with
our whole you know woven language
computational language thing to
represent uh at least well it's either
it doesn't necessarily have to be how
the actual World works because we can
invent a set of rules that aren't the
way the actual World works and run those
rules but then we're saying we're going
to accurately represent the results of
running those rules which might or might
not be the actual rules of the world but
we also are trying to capture features
of the world uh as accurately as
possible to represent what happens in
the world now again as we've discussed
you know the the atoms in the world
arrange you know you say I don't know
you know was there a tank that showed up
you know that that you know drove
somewhere okay well you know what is a
tank it's in a arrangement of atoms that
we abstractly describe as a tank and you
could say well you know there's some
arrangement of atoms that is a different
arrangement of atoms but it's and it's
not you know we didn't we didn't decide
it's like this Observer Theory question
of you know what what arrangement of
atoms counts as a tank versus not a tank
so there's there's even things that
would consider strong facts
you could start to kind of disassemble
them and show that they're not right I
mean so so the question of whether oh I
don't know
was this gust of wind strong enough to
blow over this particular thing well a
gust of wind is a complicated concept
you know it's full of little pieces of
fluid dynamics and little vortices here
and there and you have to Define you
know was it you know what the aspect of
the gust of wind that you care about
might be it put this amount of pressure
on this you know blade of some some you
know wind turbine or something
um and uh you know that that's the um um
and but but you know if you say if you
have something which is the fact of the
gust of wind was the strong or whatever
that you know that is you have to have
some definition of that you have to have
some measuring device that says
according to my measuring device that
was constructed this way the Guster wind
was this so what can you say about the
nature of truth that's useful for us to
understand chat GPT because you've been
con
you've been contending with this idea
what is fact and not and it seems like
Chachi Patrice used a lot now I've seen
it used by journalists to write articles
and so you have
um people that are working with large
language models trying to desperately
figure out how do we
essentially censor them through
different mechanisms either manually or
through reinforcement learning with
human feedback try to align them to to
not say fiction just to say non-fiction
as much as possible this is the
importance of computational language as
an intermediate it's kind of like you've
got the large language model it's able
to suffice something which is a formal
precise thing that you can then look at
and you can run tests on it and you can
do all kinds of things it's always going
to work the same way and it's precisely
defined what it does and then the large
language model is the interface I mean
the way I view these large language
models one of their important I mean
there are many use cases and you know
it's a remarkable thing to talk about
some of these you know literally you
know every day we're coming up with a
couple of new use cases
um some of which are very very very
surprising
um and things where I mean but the best
use cases are ones where it's you know
even if it gets it roughly right it's
still a huge win like a use case we had
from a week or two ago is read our bug
reports you know we've got hundreds of
thousands of bug reports that will be
accumulated over decades and it's like
you know can we have it just read the
bug report figure out where the where is
the bug likely to be and you know home
in on that piece of code maybe it'll
even suggest some some you know sort of
way to fix the code it might get that it
might be nonsense what it says to about
how to fix the code but it's incredibly
useful that it was able to you know so
awesome it's so awesome because even the
nonsense will somehow be instructive I
don't I don't quite understand that yet
I've
yeah there's so many programming related
things like uh for example uh
translating for one programming language
to another is really really interesting
it's extremely effective but then you
the failures
reveal the path forward also yeah but I
think I mean the the big thing I mean in
that kind of discussion the unique thing
about our computational language is it
was intended to be read by humans yes
and so it's really important right and
so it has this thing where you can but
but you know thinking about sort of
church EBT and its use and so on the one
of the big things about it I think is
it's a linguistic user interface that is
so a typical use case might be in the
take the journalist case for example
it's like let's say I have five facts
that I'm trying to turn into an article
or I'm trying to I'm trying to write a
report where I have basically five facts
that I'm trying to include in this
report but then I feed those five facts
to chat GPT it Puffs them out into this
big report
and then and then that's a good
interface for uh you know another if I
just gave
if I just had in my terms those five
bullet points and I gave them to some
other person the person would say I
don't know what you're talking about
because these are you know this is your
version of this sort of quick notes
about these five bullet points but if
you puff it out into this thing which is
kind of connects to the collective
understanding of language then somebody
else can look at it and say okay I
understand what you're talking about now
you can also have a situation where that
thing that was puffed out is fed to
another large language model you know
it's kind of like you know you're
applying for the permit to you know uh I
don't know grow fish in some place or
something like this and it uh you know
it it um
um and and you have these facts that
you're putting in you know I'm going to
have a you know I'm gonna you know have
this kind of water and I don't know what
it is
um you just got a few bullet points it
Puffs it out into this big application
you fill it out then at the other end
the you know the Fisheries Bureau has
another large language model that just
crushes it down because the Fisheries
Bureau cares about these three points
and it knows what it cares about and it
then so it's really the the natural
language produced by the larger language
model is sort of a transport layer that
you know is really llm communicates with
llm I mean it's kind of like the you
know I write a piece of email using my
llm and you know puff it out from the
things I want to say your llm turns it
into and the conclusion is X now the
issue is you know that the thing is
going to make this thing that is sort of
semantically plausible
and it might not actually be what you
you know it might not be kind of relate
to the world and the way that you think
it should relate to the world now I've
seen this you know I've been doing okay
I'll give you a couple of examples
um I was doing this thing when we
announced this this uh plugin for for
chat GPT I had this lovely example of a
math word problem some complicated thing
and it did a spectacular job of taking
apart this elaborate thing about you
know this person has twice as many
chickens as this et cetera et cetera et
cetera and it turned it into a bunch of
equations it fed them to a woman
language we solved the equations
everybody did great we gave back the
results and I thought okay I'm going to
put this in this blog post I'm writing
okay I thought I'd better just check and
turns out it got everything all the hard
stuff it got right in the very end last
two lines it just completely goofed it
up and gave the wrong answer
and I would not have noticed this same
thing happened to me two days ago okay
so I I thought you know I made this with
this chat gbt plug-in kit I made a thing
that would emit a sound would play a
tune on my local computer right so chat
gbt would produce you know a series of
notes and it would play this tune on my
computer very cool okay so I thought I'm
gonna ask it play the tune that Hal
sang when Hal was being disconnected in
2001 okay so it it there it is Daisy was
it Daisy yes Daisy yeah right so it's
okay so I think you know and so it
produces a bunch of notes and I'm like
this is spectacular this is amazing and
then I thought yeah I was just going to
put it in and then I thought I'd better
actually play this
and so I did and it was Mary had a
little lamb oh wow
oh wow but it was Mary had a little lamb
yeah yes wow so it's correct but wrong
yes it was uh it could easily be
mistaken yes right and in fact I I kind
of gave the I had this quote from Hal to
explain you know it's it's as a the hell
you know states in the movie you know
it's uh the HAL 9000 is you know the
thing was just a rhetorical device
because I'm realizing oh my gosh you
know this Chachi BT you know could have
easily fooled me I mean it did this it
did all the it did this amazing thing of
knowing this thing about the movie and
being able to turn that into the the
notes of the song except it's the wrong
song yeah and uh you know how in in the
movie Hal says you know I think it's
something like you know no Hal nine No 9
000 series computer has ever been found
to make an error we are for all
practical purposes perfect and um
incapable of error and I thought that
was kind of a Charming sort of uh quote
from uh from Hal to make in connection
with uh with what chat GPT yeah in that
case the interesting things about the L
alums like you said that they are very
willing to admit their error
well yes I mean that's a question of the
RH uh the reinforcement learning human
feedback thing oh right that that that's
you know
um the the really remarkable thing about
chat GPT is you know I had been
following what was happening with large
language models and I'd play with them a
whole bunch and they were kind of like
yeah you know it's kind of like what you
would expect based on sort of sort of
statistical continuation of language
it's interesting but it's not breakout
exciting and then I think the kind of
the the kind of reinforcement that the
human feedback reinforcement learning uh
you know in in making Chachi BT try and
do the things that humans really wanted
to do that broke through that kind of
reached the threshold where the thing
really is interesting to us humans and
by the way it's interesting to see how
you know you change the temperature
something like that the thing goes
Bonkers and it no longer is interesting
to humans it's producing garbage yeah um
and it's it's kind of right it's somehow
it managed to get this this Above This
threshold but it really is well aligned
to what we humans are interested in and
uh and kind of that that's um and I
think you know nobody saw that coming I
think uh certainly nobody I've talked to
and nobody who is involved in in that
project seems to have known that was
coming it's just one of these things
that is a sort of remarkable threshold I
mean you know when we built wolf from
alpha for example I didn't know it was
going to work you know we tried to build
something that would have enough
knowledge of the world that it could
answer a reasonable set of questions
that we could do that good enough
natural language understanding the
typical things you type in would work we
didn't know where that threshold was I
mean I was not sure that it was the
right decade to try and build this even
the right you know 50 years to try and
build it you know and I think that was
it's the same type of thing with chat
gbt that I don't think anybody could
have predicted said that you know 2022
would be the year that this this became
possible I think uh when you tell a
story about Marvin Minsky and showing it
to him and saying that like no no this
time it actually works yes yes you know
it's the same thing for me looking at
these large language models it's like
when when people were first saying the
first few weeks of chat gbt it's like oh
yeah you know I've seen these large
language models
um and then uh you know and then I
actually try it and uh you know oh my
gosh it actually works and I think uh
it's uh but it but you know the things
and the thing I found you know I
remember one of the first things I tried
was a write a persuasive essay that a
wolf is the bluest kind of animal okay
so it writes this thing and it starts
talking about these uh wolves that live
on the Tibetan plateau and they are
named some Latin name and so on and I'm
like really I'm starting to look it up
on the web and it's like well it's
actually complete nonsense but it's
extremely plausible I mean it's
plausible enough that I was going and
looking up on the web and wondering if
there was a wolf that was blue you know
I mentioned this on some live streams
I've done and so people have been
sending me these pictures
maybe I was onto something